so coinbase was obviously a Bitcoin only
for a long time right and it started to
add other assets anything that was
memorable as people kind of talked about
the strategy evolving from Bitcoin only
to other assets and now they're even
doing things around staking and custody
and kind of moving outside of just help
you buy Bitcoin which sounds like that
was the original mission kind of any
takeaways there yeah I mean Quinn base
was caught flat-footed I mean that's
part of these they got so beat by
finance for a while and you know sir
reason people like Olaf and Fredersen
left the company they want to spread
their wings and there's a period in
2015-16 where this Bitcoin got so bitter
between the block size debate you know
remember people wanted to expand it to
two megabytes and all that and so much
the energy was consumed in politics and
backstabbing and fighting that meanwhile
all that was going on in Bitcoin world
and then what vitalik was building you
know it was it seems suddenly very
positive you know it seems you know full
of potential so you know Fred wrote us
through a famous blog post saying hey
this is the future and he left to pursue
it and coin based his drag defeat adding
aetherium adding anything part of that
was from right for regulatory reasons to
be fair but part of it was inertia
they got complacent and then it happened
again when by Nance started adding every
token Under the Sun you know they there
was a talking coin based people were
advocating look let's split the company
into you know we'll have an
international holding company that can
go plan you know and all those markets
do the crazy stuff an American company
which they probably should have done and
but then part of it was cultural I mean
Olaf was saying you know they had such a
good 2017 they're like oh what should we
do to maximize her tax advantage rather
than building you know they lost touch
with the pulse of the crypto community
and people were like hey let's add
dogecoin which would have been an easy
lift and I like well we don't know about
the you know ROI on that and you know so
but that's when they brought Balaji in
and he you know bloody stern Avastin is
pretty famous for a variety of reasons
in crypto world and he really injected
some energy and was just like you know
hell-bent when adding tokens and that's
I think how they managed to get their
ass in here again yeah so maybe talk a
little bit more
bôla' she came into the uncom
acquisition
and became the CTO I recently had a mana
for an episode and we spent almost zero
time talking about coinbase and spent
most of the time talking about all of
the the crazy powerful ideas he has but
in terms of that acquisition if I
remember correctly that was the first
big acquisition that they did where it
was you know kind of a nine figure some
attached to it reportedly was that
specifically for kind of a change in
strategy or what was kind of the the
driving force behind rather than
building everything internally to go out
and buy a company like that blood she's
a hard figure to report on and we met
him a couple of times he's incredibly
polarizing and divisive however what
everyone agrees with is he's a genius
he's one of the sort of smartest people
in crypto and in general so the account
of you know getting earned comm you know
some people related to me that it was a
dog of a company and since andreessen
horowitz
had a big stake in that and coinbase was
a way to solve that problem a lot of
people whispered in my ear that the
official price you know the nine figures
whatever it was wasn't actually true but
it was to satisfy blood she's ego you
know I I don't take a position on that
that's what a lot of people whispering
in my ear however a blood she did do the
job in really kind of changing up the
culture at coinbase you know and it's -
well the downside was it resulted in the
Civil War I mean he pushed at him white
out he pushed a lot of people out you
know as someone called him coin bases
first brilliant [ __ ] other people
said he would win survivor you know I
don't take a position on itis there no
blood she well enough I do think he's
got formidable intelligence that's for
sure and then ultimately it became a
showdown in coin based between Asif her
G their you know Co oh and president for
a while who was making the company more
corporate and so you know which had to
be done a SIF did a lot of good things
he sort of made it into a mature company
but at the same time the rank and file
and coinbase didn't like him because he
wasn't a real crypto guy and they all
worship Balaji because blood she could
code he tokens he knew the scene he was
of it so you know and ultimately yeah I
came to a head where this you know kind
of a big bloody count and then couldn't
a lot of people and I think it forced
Bryan Armstrong to come in and lead
because you know Bryan does not like
conflict but sometimes if your
lieutenants are in a shooting war you
got to step in and do something I'm the
final straw was I guess ass if asked
Bryan's report to him on product Bryan
owns the majority of the company and as
a CEO and that was a bridge too far and
so that's when you know he got pushed
out and then balázs he on his one-year
vesting period was just he peaced out
that was that yeah
Asif obviously used to run TD Ameritrade
right so kind of came from a much more
kind of Wall Street type background yeah
and I guess part of this is not even
just coinbase but the most companies as
they go through what I was called
growing pains right there's positives
negatives and you're trying to build
something that's worth billions and
billions of dollars right so obviously
it's going to be hard to do would you
say that most people kind of understand
that it was important to have that
period where blah she came in and had an
impact it was important to have the
period where Asif came in and had an
impact and like those moments although
maybe painful at the time have kind of
built coinbase and the culture has into
today or do you feel like there's kind
of certain points in the history of
coinbase
where those that are left point back and
say hey we wish we could have skipped
over certain periods where we wouldn't
have made certain decisions in the past
that we actually ended up making no I
think that's a good way to look at the
bigger picture I mean I think people in
a start-up going through something like
that think they're the only one has
happened to you but even if you step
back and he's like look you know the
reality in the valley is a company gets
that big that quickly the executive team
is gonna turn over two or three times
you know so you're gonna have moments
like this and then you've had the hidden
hand of Andreessen the whole way too you
know I mean I think Chris Dixon and Fred
Wilson of you know Union Square Ventures
of and Barry Schulman you know you got
these real smart you know
veterans who've been kind of you know
the hidden hand shaping the path so you
know I think while it makes a good
newspaper coffee and you know silesius
book gossip I don't know if it's that
different from what goes on that you
know any tech successful tech company
that scales quickly